when the waiter comes back just ask them
to slip his number on the net any chance
you can just write your number down on
like a cedar napkin or something you
could be leavin and we'll see we did a
video together and where we were
handcuffed to each other for 24 hours
was it as terrible as I expected you
mind I thought oh this is bad my hand
and then I got burned
yeah you did get burned of all you're
trying to cut the girl I picked for will
to go on a date with I'm very proud of
myself I feel like Cupid in here because
I think that this is going to be a match
made in heaven and the twist here is
that we're going to have an earpiece
telling each other exactly what to say
what to do I feel like I'm gonna be so
tempted to just like completely sabotage
a little thing just for my own personal
entertainment pinky promise me right now
you're gonna do exactly what I tell you
to do it I would have to say I will do
exactly what I'm gonna do and I'll say
exactly what I'm gonna say so much my
hands right now so where do you live I
live in the valley but I'm originally
from Texas I'm from Charlotte North
Carolina you're that cold there it does
get cold it snows two inches the town
shows now tell her that you're from the
south so York I'm afraid of the snow
from the south so I'm a little bit
afraid of snow there's people from the
South family dropping it snows like it
will freak out would you make any fun I
moved here because I have a new job and
I wanted to put myself in an environment
that would make me grow ask her why she
moved to LA why did you move here I do
stand-up comedy
well what's like your style lately it's
been like literally like dad you ask her
for her best dad jokes tell me your best
attitude oh my gosh nobody okay uh-huh
saw a cute homeless guy the other day
guess you could call me a homeless
romantic now tell her you want to tell
her
and dad Joe I'm gonna tell you a digest
okay what did the father - nice it to
the son Jimmy I know this one
but I don't remember it go go go go
that's it no ask her what the punchline
is what do you think like the punchline
wait say it again just tell her you're
too young to look you're too young to
smoke
ah it's the worst joke ever I know that
joke because about a dad asked her what
she was like growing up so what were you
like in your burger what I am today just
like yeah you know a lot like Oh what
like of what well you just called her a
lot take back that semen I didn't mean
till you continued by saying you're a
while no it didn't I love it that's like
a compliment see how much you love her
personality I'm a lot too so I mean the
guy a lot ticket well it's better than
being boring
oh wait wait is that yeah well we'll
take a quick look the waiters hot set me
up with the waiter okay so I'm gonna
have the kale Caesar no tomatoes no
tomatoes say the reason why is because I
recently listen to a podcast with a
evolutionary biologist and he said
tomatoes are indigenously poisonous to
humans and most people don't know well I
actually don't want tomatoes my meal
because I listened to a podcast recently
that says that tomatoes are indigenously
contagious poisonous not contain
poisonous in humans
peanuts - peanuts - he sounds so Ellen
don't tomatoes for me everybody know la
is like this is bad for you don't you
it's gonna kill you I'm out no I'm just
gonna thank you thank you so you got
bread and tomatoes I didn't know it came
with bread am I breaking some la ruler
yeah you're so not only what is it
called again that's all it's what you
put on your eyes look yeah that's a
cucumber cucum right yeah I do get
conversion I do like they're feeding
each other that's good because we here
ask her what she likes to do
every time I like going to Mahon drive
versus in-between Studio City in
Hollywood okay Jim Carrey is the one who
inspired me to do stand-up comedy but he
used to go to the top of mall and drive
and ride himself like a I know it go to
the top of the mouth and you'd ride
himself a bit sure yeah so there's a few
babes and they're law of attraction
let's say with the seductive twinkle in
your eye
do you believe in the law of attraction
how you saying that's what you desire
yeah how you manifest what you desire oh
yeah okay let's come back you know
you're so funny yeah
everybody now lies about the universe is
amazing
wait we'll ask the waiter for his number
uh scuse me sir actually tell them
you're asking for friends is there any
chance I can hear your phone number
you're asking a very front oh I don't I
don't personally want it but - yeah um
he hasn't even asked for my number and
you're lucky right tell her sorry about
that I was awesome pretty friends you're
there so there's one see you are you're
gonna be funny - thank you know he's
doing with you a hallway bit ask her
what she looks for in a partner
ooh that's easy someone who's funny so
excellent I know someone who eats
dressing just kidding he's it's about
the salad
wha-ha-ha-ha-ha ask her how she thinks
the dates going so far it's like a lot
of fun I've been on a date a while so
it's a lot of fun cuz I'm gonna date a
law or it's actually a lot of fun in
general it's a great date okay it's a
great date look I don't know they'll all
be there really I'm taking all the
credit for this you saved yourself for
now like I asked her if she liked to go
in a second date I know I haven't been
super hilarious this whole date and this
has been like okay in the wine he's
discrediting would you want a second
date
heck yeah yeah where where I'm not going
to tell you I love surprises yeah you
totally team me up and you gave me all
the ammo that I needed and that's why
next time I go on a date I'm gonna put
you in my ear again okay that will be
$500 please and I I can walk away
knowing
that in karmic law this will come back
around
[Music]
so we'll set up a second date for you in
hundred dollars an hour
[Music]